Let's go !
C'est trop cool le char à voile...
C'est Christophe Galtier
qui t'a donné l'idée.
Je suis avec des clowns.
Pas mal, cette sortie en char à voile.
- Pile à l'heure, glisse ton sac.
- Ouais
- On passe chercher Virginie...
- OK.
Et on file sur la côte.
En voiture électrique, en plus visiblement, non ?
Ben oui, je suis tes conseils.
C'est vrai.
Char à voile, voiture électrique,
on est sur du voyage
responsable j'ai l'impression.
C'est ça moque tout de moi.
N'empêche qu'on va profiter du voyage
pour éclaircir certains points sur la voiture électrique.
Tiens, 2035, ça te dit quelque chose ?
Pas grand chose je crois...
Et bien en 2035, on va arrêter de vendre
des voitures thermiques.
- OK
- et à cette date il y aura environ
15 millions de véhicules électriques en France, alors...
Autant prendre de l'avance.
C'est ça.
Allez,
on y va, on est un peu en retard.
Tu as mis le contact là ?
- Par ce que j'ai rien entendu
- Ouais ouais.
Ben, regarde.
Ah oui carrément... (rire)
C'est vrai que c'est de l'électrique.
On entend jamais rien de l'électrique en fait.
- Non
- C'est silencieux.
- Tu as ton permis au fait Jamy ?
Euh...Mais oui bien sûr.
C'est quand même vraiment silencieux.
Silencieux et en plus,
je ne sais pas si tu ressens,
mais il n'y a pas de vibration.
Et alors, l'autre gros avantage, ben c'est
une voiture électrique,
elle n'émet pas de gaz d'échappement.
Du coup, quand il y a des pics de pollution
comme ça se passe souvent
dans les grosses agglomérations,
ce type de véhicule peut rouler.
Par contre, il y a un sujet par rapport
aux voitures électriques,
qui revient souvent, c'est l'autonomie.
Parce que tu sais, entre l'autonomie annoncée,
l'autonomie réelle,
l'autonomie en ville, par exemple,
et sur l'autoroute,
on s'y perd un peu quoi.
En fait, une voiture comme celle-ci,
elle a une autonomie de 230 kilomètres
WLTP Mixte.
- (rire) C'est quoi ?
- Ce qui est pas mal pour une voiture
de ce type.
Une citadine électrique.
C'est quoi WLTP mixte ? On dirait Tennis Poker Worldwide... (rire)
Ah ça, j'y peux rien.
C'est pas moi qui l'ait inventé.
En fait, c'est un acronyme anglais.
Alors je ne vais pas rentré
dans les détails parce que...
Je veux entendre ton accent anglais.
C'est mon accent
et je ne veux pas te faire peur.
En fait, c'est une norme internationale
qui a été mise au point
pour pouvoir comparer justement
toutes les voitures électriques
parce que évidemment,
elles n'ont pas toutes les mêmes batteries
et donc pas toutes la même autonomie.
Par contre le côté mixte, tu me l'a pas
trop expliqué dans le WL Tennis Poker...
(rires)
On dit mixte
parce que quand on teste les véhicules,
on les teste à la fois en ville
et on les test aussi en cycle extra urbain,
c'est-à-dire
sur des voies rapides ou des autoroutes.
OK, et ça,
ça change beaucoup pour l'autonomie.
Ah oui, ça change énormément
parce que je disais que cette voiture
avait une autonomie de 230 kilomètres.
En ville, ça monte à 300, 310.
Donc ça n'a rien à voir.
Oui et tout ça parce que,
je ne sais pas si tu as remarqué, mais quand on est en ville,
on passe beaucoup de temps
à freiner, à ralentir.
Et ce qui est intéressant
avec ce véhicule, c'est que,
à chaque fois que tu freines ou que tu ralentis,
eh bien, on va récupérer l'énergie cinétique de la voiture
pour recharger la batterie.
Tandis que sur l'autoroute,
comme tu as à une vitesse
constante, au final,
tu peux pas récupérer.
Cette autonomie va diminuer de...
50%.
- Alors pour autant, il ne faut pas en tirer de conclusions hâtives.
Parce qu'il
faut savoir qu'en moyenne en France,
une voiture parcourt
35 kilomètres par jour.
Ce sont des petits trajets
pour conduire les enfants
à l'école,
aller faire les courses, aller au travail,
quand t'es en ville et que tu as 300 kilomètres d'autonomie.
C'est large.
C'est même plus d'une semaine de trajet.
En sachant que tu peux recharger chez toi
les soirs.
(rires)
Ah tiens, il y a Virginie là, regarde.
Tu peux te garer je pense.
- Salut Virginie.
- Salut les garçons.
Merci Jamy pour l'invitation.
- C'est trop cool le char à voile.
- Je t'en prie.
C'est Christophe Galtier
qui t'a donné l'idée ?
Oh...
Je suis avec des clowns,
(rires)
Ça va bien se passer.
Allez, c'est parti !
J'annonce juste que Jamy ne m'a pas montré son permis encore...
Je ne suis pas sûr à 100%, mais...
Moi non plus.
(rires)
On y va en électrique, c'est cool.
C'est vrai
qu'on en voit de plus en plus en ville.
Il y a de plus en plus de places
avec des bornes.
Mais là, on va sur la côte et
je comprends un petit peu
les réticences des personnes qui se disent
mais est-ce qu'on va trouver
des bornes de recharge ?
Alors pour être tout à fait franc
avec vous.
L'autoroute, c'est pas forcément
le terrain de jeu
de la voiture électrique, surtout
comme celle-ci, une citadine électrique.
Pour autant,
on peut quand même s'y aventurer.
Il faut seulement anticiper,
prévoir son trajet.
Et ça, c'est le rôle du copilote.
- C'est moi le copilote.
- Non, c'est ton téléphone.
- Yes, ok. Ravi d'être venu.
- Voilà.
C'est quoi le lien entre le téléphone
et le copilote ?
Tu vas trouver plein d'applications,
des planificateurs de trajets
qui vont nous éviter
des petits désagréments.
OK, attends,
je fais une petite recherche alors.
Génération Y tu connais.
- Oui
- Enfin, pas trop toi...
- Facile !
- L'insolence !
L'insolence de la jeunesse.
OK, j'ai trouvé Chargemap par exemple.
Ça te parle ?
Ça me parle, très très bien.
Alors l'itinéraire.
On va à Honfleur, ville...
la plus romantique de France
messieurs, dames.
Est-ce que tu nous amènes là-bas pour ça d'ailleurs ?
Non. (rires)
95% de batterie, on va mettre 30%
de marge à peu près.
- Ça te va ?
- Ça me va.
Le modèle Dacia Spring, on est pas mal.
Vitesse max, tu as l'air assez tranquille Jamy.
- Oui. Ça j'aime bien rouler cool.
- 110 ?
Let's go ! On en a pour...
Oh ça va, 2 h et demie, c'est pas si loin.
- Non
- Donc avec un petit arrêt
qui sera dans 38 minutes environ.
Parfait pour un café.
Tu nous mets de la musique
pour qu'on puisse s'ambiancer un peu.
Qu'est-ce que je vous mets ?
C'est quoi tes goûts du moment ?
Un peu d'électro,
ça vous dit ?
- Pas mal.
- Électro, électrique...
Le lien est là, très fort
car il est très très fort.
Il est pas là pour être ici Jamy. Vas-y.
Allez, c'est parti.
Bien conduit. Respect.
Ça fait du bien de se dégourdir un peu
les jambes.
Bon, là, c'est bien,
il y a 5 bornes de voiture,
mais si tout le monde se met
à l'électrique, il y en aura jamais assez.
Et ça me fait penser à...
Vous avez pas vu l'image aux États-Unis ?
Pour Thanksgiving, il y avait des files d'attente jusqu'à l'autoroute.
Bon, on en est quand même pas encore là.
C'est vrai qu'on a pris un peu de retard.
J'aime bien les chiffres.
Fin octobre 2022,
il y avait un peu plus de 75000 bornes
publiques installées sur le territoire.
C'est moins que ce qui était prévu de base, non ?
Moins, parce qu'il était prévu 100000. Ok, alors ça progresse
et de plus en plus vite.
Et l'objectif,
c'est 7 millions de bornes en 2030.
Alors 7 millions de bornes publiques
et privées parce qu'il faut jamais oublier
que en général, on recharge sa voiture
soit à la maison, soit au bureau.
J'ai branché.Tu as ta carte ?
Hein ?
(rires)
- Non non je ne sais pas.
- Je crois que tu vas pousser.
On va se prendre un petit café.
- Allez !
- On a combien de temps là ?
- 30 minutes.
- Ah ben parfait !
On va aussi pouvoir prendre une viennoiserie
- Team chocolatine ou un pain au chocolat ?
Pain au chocolat !
Moi j'aime les deux
- On commence les choses sérieuses.
- Je vais acheter des bonbons.
Bon, moi je me prends un café.
Elle est toujours là, hein ?
Ouf !
Mais quand est-ce qu'on sait que
la batterie est suffisamment rechargée ?
La voiture est connectée à mon téléphone.
Stylé !
Et il suffit de consulter l'écran
et je vois là par exemple...
Un écureuil !
Non, elle est chargée à 100%.
Donc il est temps de terminer
notre café et de reprendre la route.
Alors par contre on était bien au chaud
et là on va entrer dans une voiture bien froide.
C'est pas un problème non plus !
Parce que je peux commander à distance
le chauffage de la voiture.
C'est ce que j'ai fait d'ailleurs.
Donc, on va rentrer dans la voiture.
- Tu nous as mis 22 degrés ?
- Exactement !
Et en plus,
ce qui est super intéressant,
c'est que ça ne pompe pas sur la batterie.
Étant donné que la voiture est branchée
sur le secteur.
Est-ce que c'est la même chose
du coup sur la clim en été ?
Exactement.
Donc l'intérêt
c'est de refroidir la voiture
quand elle est en charge comme ça.
On la met à 19, 20 degrés,
on monte dans la voiture et là
il y a juste à maintenir la température.
- Ok trop cool.
- Pratique.
- On y va du coup ?
- Allez !
Alors du coup, c'est combien le plein Jamy ?
Et bien là, ça m'a coûté 10€,
10€ pour 100 kilomètres.
C'est quand même assez cher, non ?
Je pensais que c'était plus accessible l'électrique.
Ben ça c'est
parce qu'on est sur une borne rapide
et que le kilowattheure est à 0,69€
d'euros.
Bon, faut se rappeler que, en général,
on recharge la voiture électrique
à la maison ou au bureau.
À la maison, ça revient à combien du coup ?
En ce moment, c'est 0,13€
le kilowattheure, donc
2€ pour 100 kilomètres.
Ouais, là c'est beaucoup plus accessible pour le coup.
C'est honnête, hein ?
- Bon, je peux conduire ou... Allez.
- Évidemment.
Vous inquiétez pas, j'ai le permis.
Jamy t'es copilote, tu gères l'application.
Moi, je vais faire une petite sieste.
Comme ça, c'est les chaises musicales.
OK.
Alors Virginie, première impression,
ça donne quoi ?
Et ben très cool.
Déjà, je la trouve très silencieuse
et c'est vrai qu'elle est très souple.
Et quand t'appuies, c'est assez réactif, ça avance bien.
Ouais, je le ressens derrière, tu appuies pas mal.
Je vais me calmer, alors.
Alors en fait, ça c'est une histoire de couple.
Ah... Est-ce que c'est lié à Honfleur ?
De couple moteur.
C'est-à-dire que l'énergie du moteur
est directement disponible pour les roues,
pour faire avancer la voiture,
à la différence d'une voiture thermique
où là ça doit passer par une bielle,
un vilebrequin, une boîte de vitesse,
des courroies, etc, etc...
Il y a beaucoup de déperdition d'énergie.
Après, ce qui est vraiment bien aussi,
c'est que ça ne rejette pas de CO2
et ça avec l'urgence climatique,
c'est très important.
Ouais mais alors moi
je me suis toujours posé la question,
peut être que Jamy tu vas pouvoir
me répondre là dessus,
c'est que
on entend souvent
qu'avec les constructions
des batteries etc, ce n'est pas non plus si écolo que ça.
Ben ouais, c'est vrai,
la voiture électrique,
il a fallu la fabriquer,
pour la fabriquer, eh bien, il faut des matières premières, donc des ressources,
de l'énergie, au final, en sortie d'usine,
une voiture électrique a une dette carbone
plus importante
qu'une voiture thermique.
Elle a plus pollué à la construction.
Exactement.
Mais bon, pour comparer voiture électrique et voiture thermique, eh bien,
il faut prendre en compte la fabrication,
bien sûr, mais aussi tout le cycle de vie.
OK, et il y a des études
qui nous donnent des chiffres ?
Oui, il y a des études.
Elles arrivent toutes à la même conclusion.
C'est qu'à partir
d'un certain moment, c'est-à-dire
30, 40000 kilomètres,
2 ou 3 ans,
un peu plus court pour les voitures comme celle-ci,
les citadines, certaines citadines.
La voiture électrique a moins d'impact sur l'environnement
que la voiture thermique.
Et du coup, est-ce qu'il
y a des études aussi sur le long terme ?
Alors, sur le long terme, au bout de
150000 kilomètres, une voiture électrique
aura émis 4 fois moins de CO2
qu'une voiture thermique.
Donc c'est quand même très intéressant.
Et ça, c'est d'autant plus vrai que là,
on est dans une petite citadine,
donc la batterie est beaucoup plus petite
que pour un gros SUV
- où là l'empreinte écologique est plus importante.
Après la voiture électrique,
c'est pas non plus l'unique solution.
C'est toute notre vision de la mobilité
qu'il faut changer.
Il n'y a pas que la voiture électrique,
il y a aussi
le covoiturage, la voiture partagée,
le transport en commun bien sûr.
- Le vélo !
- ou même le char à voile, par exemple.
N'est-ce pas ?
Rigole toi, on va faire une course !
Tu vas voir.
Par ce qu'on arrive là.
Les paris sont lancés.
Est-ce que vous connaissez Honfleur ?
Parce que c'est quand même
la 6ème ville
la plus visitée de France ?
La ville des amoureux,
vous l'avez bien compris.
Il y a plein de petits quartiers
qui valent le détour.
Comme juste là d'ailleurs.
Je sais pas, si voyez les maisons,
c'est magnifique avec le port.
Quartier de l'Enclos,
tout ça.
Le bassin est superbe.
Bon promis, on fera ça après le char à voile,
parce que là on est pile dans les temps.
- OK, je voulais visiter un peu.
- Vous voyez...
On est arrivé pile à l'heure
comme le dit Virginie,
et en plus, on n'a même pas eu le temps
de parler de météo et de voyage.
Donc vous voyez, on va aller se garer
sur le parking de la mairie,
il y a des bornes de recharge.
Et puis, pendant ce temps là...
À nous le char à voile !
Alors la première chose, c'est que je vais
vous demander de monter dans vos chars.
Vérifiez que vous pouvez diriger
avec vos pieds.
Une fois, que ça c'est fait.
On vous met donc au travers,
perpendiculaire à l'axe du vent,
et c'est parti pour aller faire
le premier virage là bas, dos au vent.
Let's go !!!
Comme tu dis : je ne suis pas là pour être ici.
Bon Bruno, c'était comment ?
Intense !
(rires)
Bonsoir.